[Music]
fans waited six long years to watch
vanellope and ralph embark on their
newest and even crazier adventure
we're guessing that disney writer's room
was loaded with ideas and story lines
that just didn't make the cut into the
final film that we all know and love
but don't worry we won't leave you
hanging today we're gonna go through all
the crazy ideas and amazing deleted
scenes
that we think would make this flick even
better where are
you we're friends of vanellope's one of
the film's biggest highlights is the 13
disney princesses that vanellope
stumbles upon during her quest
hi while the princesses certainly make
their mark on the movies
the directors revealed they actually cut
part of their scenes here's one of those
cuts
when we think of princess jasmine we
immediately think of her furry companion
raja before being cut there was a scene
showing jasmine actually being allergic
to raja
the joke was supposed to be jasmine
huffing and puffing on an inhaler
and raja giving her a side eye
ultimately this cute little interaction
was taken out and we honestly can't see
why
your princess bff is snow white
another iconic princess that makes her
way into wreck-it ralph 2 is the one and
only snow white
before being cut the movie attempted to
explain why snow white always looked so
surprised
apparently her constantly wide eyes were
supposed to be because our girl snow is
legally blind but never were her glasses
we guess that's because beauty is pain
or in snow white's case blurry is beauty
another cool moment we hoped would make
it into the movies is actually a bunch
of selfies
before the release of the film selfies
of vanellope with all the 13 princesses
featured in the film
started to circulate the internet silly
shots and beauty shots of all the girls
would have been really cool while it's
not clear if those pictures were merely
intended for marketing purposes and not
for the final movies we still kind of
got our hopes up
five minutes princesses in 2012
disney paid over 4 billion dollars to
acquire the rights to star wars so it
makes sense that they want to get their
money's worth by adding iconic star wars
characters to an already stacked
wreck-it ralph 2 cast
unfortunately for star wars die-hard
fans c-3po's extended scene is cut
quite short when c-3po comes into the
green room the war supposed princesses
poke fun at the robot in this cute
encounter cinderella mistakenly calls
him r2d2
sleeping beauty steps in to tell
cinderella that c-3po hates being called
that but then follows up by saying be
right there bb-8 having had enough of
the trolling princesses
c-3po leaves and exclaims such insolence
you're good with princesses they said
you'll love this job oh how i long for
the days of captain solo
the hilarious scene was probably trimmed
in order to make room for the insane
amount of high profile characters in the
movie this way
speaking of c3po here's another blow to
star wars fans
the last jedi's ruthless villain kylo
ren was originally supposed to make an
appearance in wreck-it ralph 2.
in the star wars trilogy ren is
portrayed as a very serious dark
character
one you wouldn't typically find in an
animated movie wreck-it ralph's 2
director rich moore revealed they
originally wanted to make a joke about
kylo ren
being a spoiled bratty child
unfortunately the idea was quickly nixed
by lucasfilm
who said they'd really prefer if disney
left their villain alone
to the disappointment of the directors
and star wars fans everywhere
that bit of loving satire never made its
way into the movie
i failed you ben i'm sorry
i'm sure you are emo did you like the
movie sweetie
fans who are in the know know to stay
until the very end of the credits
in the case of wreck-it ralph 2 savvy
fans are rewarded with not one but two
additional scenes the hilarious pancake
milkshake scene probably seemed familiar
to some
as it was included in the first teaser
trailer after going into production the
filmmakers were stuck making a difficult
choice they realized that the scene just
didn't work in the film but because they
released it to the public it had to be
there if at all possible
it's crazy to think how much the movie
must have changed one of the director
even states
we would have bet money this is going to
be in to make matters even worse
people were so crazy about the bunny in
the deleted scene toys were even being
modeled after it
luckily the directors finally came up
with a solution to add the scene
after the credits
another set of superstar characters that
didn't make the cut are none other than
mario and luigi
and before you google it no disney does
not
actually own the rights to the dynamic
duo the directors had to make a deal
with tech giant nintendo
in order to put them in the movie during
the production of the original wreck-it
ralph movie
the directors intended on using mario
and luigi but eventually decided against
it
however when making the second film
director rich moore stated he did want
mario to appear sadly for super mario
fans by the time the sequel was in
production the rights had run out and
were no longer available to disney
[Music]
uh favorites
fix it felix and calhoun had a much
smaller role in wreck-it ralph 2.
although they still had their moments
the two were originally intended to play
a much larger role in the sequel we were
supposed to see how the newlyweds coping
or not with the struggles of parenting
parenting is horrible no one ever tells
you to be like this
japan's beloved tinkerbell makes a brief
appearance in the final cut of record
ralph 2
but originally she was intended for a
much larger role
in the clip shown at d23 tinkerbell
tickles ralph's nose until ralph has had
enough and insults her
playfully calling her stinker smell the
adorable moment was eventually cut
before it made its way to the big screen
the cut occurred after there was a
change made to the story and the scene
no longer worked with the rest of the
movie come on
princesses and cartoon characters blame
stormtroopers stan lee and all of the
disney princesses
apparently wasn't enough for wreck-it
ralph 2's cast the directors intended
for vanellope to encounter none other
than the golden girls
although the cameo was written planned
out and delivered to the animators
ultimately the directors decided to cut
the girls the golden girls first aired
back in 1985
way before disney's target audience so
they were worried that the reference
might go over people's heads
bummer for blanche rose dorothy and
sophia but lucky for us wreck-it ralph 2
is doing just fine without an extra
cameo
or four easy there oh i mean
no offense or anything speaking of tough
cuts
this next scene was supposed to pay a
cute homage to the beloved disney
classic lady and the [ __ ] in the film
when ralph goes to the dark net he meets
the two-headed war man double dan the
directors originally intended to place a
lady in the [ __ ] moment here
each of the two heads were supposed to
share a virus together and just like the
iconic spaghetti scene in lady and the
[ __ ]
the two heads were going to end up
kissing are you sure this is safe
is it safe of course it is next up is
one of the biggest cuts on this list
the character bev which stands for built
to eradicate viruses was cut entirely
from the final film
at one point during production bev
served as the main antagonist of the
sequel
before being nixed bev was supposed to
be the overlord of the internet
built to eradicate all internet viruses
the character was actually supposed to
be modeled after one of the film
director's mothers
eventually like everything else on this
list the filmmakers opted to cut bev and
the idea of a villain altogether
maybe she went down to the airbud
pavilion come on let's check it out
fun-loving dumbo unfortunately didn't
make his way onto the big screen for the
final cut of the film
during the chase sequence between
vanellope and the stormtroopers
vanellope was originally supposed to
escape by climbing onto dumbo's back and
flying away
instead the final film cuts the sequence
way downtown
and vanellope merely escapes by running
into the princess's dressing room
superheroes in new york
marvel's own stan lee was in fact
quickly featured in the sequel
in the scene where vanellope is
frantically trying to get away from a
gaggle of stormtroopers
she passes countless recognizable faces
during the chase
vanellope races past stan lee the scene
shows stan lee interacting with his own
creation
iron man but nothing is said by stan
this cameo was actually intended to be a
part of a much larger scene
the directors initially envisioned an
elaborate scene in which we'd see
characters including stan lee marvelized
by going through a special machine the
scene was ultimately cut so fans never
got to see which character stan lee was
going to be marvelized into
even after stan's unfortunate passing
he's still making his way into the
marvel and disney universes we love
so much i've always wanted to be
appreciated as a real hero
so what did you make of this list do you
think the writers should have
reconsidered leaving some of these epic
scenes or story lines out
or is the movie as is the perfect
balance of disney inside jokes and
easter eggs
let us know in the comments below what
your favorite scene in wreck ralph 2 is
and what you hope to see in the third
installment